[__] the whatever that like uh jar or
that like can of fish is it's like the
super stinky fish from like you know
what I'm talking about summer
stroming and then find the the military
guy eating
it he holds his up and the can is
completely like has uh I forget what the
what the term is but it's basically gone
bad so there's too much air in it oh
there's a certain term for it like
people die eating canned [__] that's
gone bad you're right so he holds the
can up he has no idea and he's like this
[__] thing's like hard as hell
fermented fish and salt water botulism
it's called and sure you've all seen
that other videos so we're going to do
it but uh the can is so
pressurized it's gonna pop that's just
like carbon dioxide and like yeah dude
all the yeah all the gases released from
from the bacteria eating the [__]
awesome yeah s there man look at that
[__] this pressurized as hell he
going to pop due dat
nervous this is the funniest thing in
the world every time someone cracks his
stuff oh God that can farts that's how
bad it smells that can farted I think it
queefed yeah not as bad as I thought it
was going to
smell but that could just
be
[Laughter]
that one
hit just right
away he's laughing in between them
two that's
awful we got it can you guys get some of
this stuff oh no no let's do this next
time I I mean I I just want to smell it
I need to know oh yeah actually then let
dude let's get some of this open and
spill it on the
[Laughter]
carpet sorry man I was just thinking
everything you just said could pass his
like horny uh Instagram comments it was
I need to smell
it I need to smell it I just need to
know do it fart do it fart play it
damn it's so bad it is it's
rough come
on
hey oh bro look at how this
looks I'm a puke looking at that dude
look at there's no meat he can't get any
solid chunks you good say flakes it's
it's waned a little bit okay I'm try
trying to find a piece of fish there a
lot of bone but no fish lot of bone no
meat [__] oh
sh [__] okay it you'll get a spoonful of
the juice of the juice oh that smells so
bad
[Laughter]
oh
as that's not as's o
so wait if you just Google botulism it's
like man dies man dies woman dies woman
dies woman
dies it's like crazy
dangerous rare but serious illness
caused by a toxin that attacks the
body's nerves and causes difficulty
breathing muscle paralysis and even
death awesome yeah so it's I think this
is
uh it's like when canned [__] goes bad
like I don't know sometimes it happens
in restaurants and stuff too so new fear
unlocked that's awesome that's
awesome wait what uh where where does it
come from Sir on average about 110 cases
of botulism are reported in the US every
year what's the stinky fish where is it
made
Summerstone I don't think it's summer is
it sir
struming sir struming how do you say
that
Swedish from Sweden sing Sweden s
straming sir straming I'm sure you have
to really lean to that St Str
straing something like that it's not
that
bad
balloons these balloons are like
assaulting
you
don't this is what's in
the that's summer strong yeah summer
strong just going to keep [__] it up
strong whatever it
is that's what I get for okay you're
going to can you can you focus for two
seconds I can you're going to love this
okay let me Focus okay so this guy
brings in some homemade QR code menus
into Cheesecake Factory okay and I'll
let I'll let the video play and show you
what's on them if you're listening on
audio get with the times mhm should have
an iPad in your steering
wheel oh this is good this is good this
is good it says special menu on
[Laughter]
it
so hella free meals hell free
meals oh you didn't film anyone's
reaction no come on man you got to get
people scanning that
thing can you describe the video for the
audio listeners for if you're listening
on
audio um you can go [__] yourself no I'm
just kidding it's
a
picture a
hippopotamus now think about its ass I
guess when hippopotamus is Po poop their
tails like FL side to side like funniest
thing ever no that's a turd cutter yeah
that's T yeah that's act tur cutter
yeah why does it do that it turns the
[__] into Silly String why does it do
that like you know when you spray Silly
String it doesn't come out as a string
it just kind of like like cakes out yeah
picture that and then a tail just
whipping it back and
forth damn that comment mck
spreading mck spreading it's uh I
learned what it's called from an AVGN
video what is AVGN isn't that like the
porn award yeah isn't it that's AVN yeah
not that we would know Angry Video Game
ner oh got it got it mck
spreading keep scrolling
down uh it's a different kind of
Cheesecake
Factory thanks [__]
yeah